absolute union of cheese we've got going
on it's like 15 cups of parmesan a lot
of onions to get through a lot of tears
to cry whoo
take a breather not really sure why I'm
doing this but helps
hi my name is Alvin
I am a tasty producer and I love making
giant food for other people for the past
two years I've been playing video games
with a couple of friends from work and
this one guy Jake he is always eat
before we play while we play after we
play all the time so I thought it'd be
kind of fun to make him something giant
for him to snack on because this guy
eats a lot let's go me jaqen see what he
wants to eat today too you know just
same old work in yeah hard so I've told
people that we play games online a lot
yes and also you are always eating I
just always like to have one with me is
that why you're like always peppered
that video is eating I think there's a
correlation yeah I also do want to make
you a giant food so is there anything in
particular that you think would be fun
to just snack on I mean I love fried
foods okay my Mike my main finger food
is uh like mozzarella sticks okay how
about at one of you what if I made you
both mozzarella sticks but honey drinks
I feel like they go together like onion
rings actually with my gateway into
onions you like onions before and then
onion rings I was like it is our bed I
think I can get into it gotta go make
these giant mozzarella sticks and giant
onion rings and hopefully then I could
beat you as well because maybe you'll be
too preoccupied
yeah that's handy you can feel free to
hang out here I'm gonna get to it and
see if I can make that happen alright
thanks to appreciate it yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
okay so today we're gonna be making
giant onion rings you also might have
seen them on some other YouTube channels
so it's not exactly the newest concept
but we're gonna try it to make our own
version so my technique is basically
instead of making one like giant onion
ring is to shape onions into a ring
instead
and not have to deal with finding it a
ring that's like this big so I'm just
gonna kinda throw a couple of these here
there's a lot of onions can you smell it
already
oh yeah we're gonna need some tissues
over here I'm going to actually sprinkle
some salt in it because I want to draw
out as much water as I can because I
don't want the onion ring to be really
wet
that's delicious as you can see if you
have a bit of a onion puree and going on
we're actually just gonna dump it into a
bowl with cheesecloth I'm gonna do this
a couple more times that's looking
pretty good around two's done this is
the onion puree mixture that we have I
don't think I can put the rest of this
in there yet so I'm actually just gonna
take this out and squeeze it to get all
the juices really so getting it
everywhere
all right Alvin you can do this
blindfolded it's feeling like a diaper
now yeah so a lot of Tears right now I
think the last time I cried this much I
washed the vendors and Game of Thrones
in the same night that's pretty intense
oh my god okay actually I think this is
making me cry a little
oh all right I want to say it's good for
round number one whoa take a breather
I'm Fanning my own eyes I want to power
through it you know no one ever said
this was gonna be easy you know
sometimes it doesn't kill you makes you
stronger fingers crossed this doesn't
take me out but we'll see it's actually
good kind of a tense little grab a fan
oh okay that's nice
we're gonna keep going and thank you
appreciate it you're a real fan oh I
can't get over the amount of liquid
coming out though that's just wild so
let's see what we got
yes nice ball of squeezed up onions whoa
okay I had to take a little nap in the
back eyes are killing me our fan is
still on but we're gonna add some
binders in here to make this into a ring
so I have some cornstarch and I have
some egg white just gonna keep mixing
until all the moisture absorbs start
with this much actually really nice and
soft to play with gonna make a hole in
the middle there we go get into a ring
kind of shape hopefully it holds
together in the freezer shaping it it's
coming together I think that's a pretty
good looking onion ring we got going on
okay I'm gonna make one more I have high
hopes for this one their strategy is to
get this into a nice circle and then
make the hole in the middle gotta be
good the fingers here cuz you got to
shape it into a nice bowl like a donut I
say that these are two pretty
nice-looking onion rings we got some
more of this onion batter I want to take
these into the freezer and then we're
gonna get some stuff ready and probably
go work on some mozzarella sticks so
here we go
onion rings are in the freezer in the
meantime we're gonna make giant
mozzarella sticks
we got like six pound blocks
oh my god Oh to bisect this in entire
log we got here okay look at that all
right
next cut don't go when you it was so
hard to cut the cheese that's some big
sticks we got we're gonna cut these all
up first there we go okay we've got four
blocks turn these into some sticks we
could you know it's batter and fry this
one I honestly don't think that's big
enough so I'm gonna try to get these two
to go back-to-back I think this might be
easier if I break this in half all right
there you go okay we gotta get another
one to cross over
these are skewered together we're gonna
put them in the freezer to set up and
you know I'm gonna hang out in the back
probably gonna eat half of this turn the
rest of this into more mozzarella sticks
so I'll be back we have to make the
breading that's like a landslide over
here they call this the big summit of
panko well ask an avalanche in a
rainstorm of grated Parmesan cheese but
this is mozzarella stick and it tastes
pretty damn good I'll tell you that and
you know just some salt as you got us
still season your stuff then dry parsley
flakes for color and for a little bit of
flavor it was gonna get in here whisk
all this together
oh that turn into like a landscape I'm
gonna say at least probably ten loaves
of bread were used to make these bread
crumbs pretty much there now we gotta
whisk our 32 eggs
look at this beautiful color you got
going on alright so I'm gonna go grab
those mozzarella sticks and we're gonna
probably make a huge mess they're trying
to bread them but we're gonna do it for
Jake let's go make it happen okay
well we have four skewer together die
mozzarella sticks I think it's time to
bread them this is a 100% going to get
very messy so put on some gloves here we
go go in here coat them in the egg all
righty I'm just gonna throw these on
here I'm gonna do that well this is the
biggest thing I think I've ever breaded
here at tasty in the back of the eggs
get coated flip it around back in the
breadcrumbs oh here we go okay it's
getting it's getting a little coat I'm
into it okay this guy's pretty much
ready
that was one we're gonna do a couple
more all right here we go number two oh
this is pretty nerve-wracking yes yeah
these are four giant mozzarella sticks
we got some extra breading I might go
make some more because you know I think
it's always fun to have more cheese I'm
gonna take two these to the freezer see
you guys later okay oh there's like the
pancakes
cool I'm hearing batters so got a big
bowl of flour here then we're just gonna
add in our seasoning so got some cool
seasoning salt and regular salt some
pepper and whisking it together get a
nice color in there all right that's in
and we're gonna go with boil a lot of
eggs and then just a lot of milk cool I
like living life on the edge you know
oh the momentum from the hips helps to
better not drip I'm gonna take this to
the back and I get some help because I'm
pretty much exhausted and I'm gonna go
to bed okay as you can see this is a
very large pot with a lot of hot oil
please do not try this at home I'm very
excited to see how this all turns out
and let's get to it okay let's go here
one on this is the mozzarella stick
we're going in folks
snow there goes we are frying at around
three ninety four hundred degrees this
is gonna fry for about I'm gonna say
like two to three minutes it doesn't
take a long time so we'll give it a
look-see
oh let's look good real good that's fine
really quick oh right we might be able
to take this guy out let's get in here
with one of these you got this guy all
right
this is our mozzarella stick screed our
golden brown now we're coming out whoo
that's a mozzarella stick okay we made
two more mozzarella sticks so now we
have four and now we're gonna move on to
onion rings so this is gonna go into the
cornstarch gonna absorb any excess
moisture from the onions I'm gonna ask
for a set Pelt Brian can you give me a
hand here
this is Ryan he's on our culinary team
he's amazing and he is the reason why
this video is going to work you want to
hold the bowl right next to the oil this
will be a two-man effort go in oh that's
kind of cool okay
thanks for holding Ryan so let's see if
we can get this under here we got a drip
off any of the excess you got in the
back here goes nothing guys
whoo all right well that's what you can
do with the power of teamwork Thank You
Ryan this is at around 350 or so 370 ish
because there were onions inside our
Rauf so we need to cook them through
just like an onion ring so this is gonna
fry I'm gonna say like 10-15 minutes
until it's golden brown and crispy and
then check back on it okay it's been 15
minutes the color is really nice I think
that looks like an onion ring coming out
all right
I got probably two more to go because
you can't have a complete set without
four ring and then four sticks so got a
lot more batter to go through see you
guys in a bit
we did it tried a lot of stuff we got
400 rings we've got four mozzarella
sticks but I think it's time to really
assemble these just like Captain America
says we got some really cool containers
for the onion rings this guy's goes
first right hanging out this guy coming
over here then we're gonna get my boy
onion ring number three and then final
guy those are the four onion rings
let's go plate the mozzarella sticks all
right one two three all right this one
goes in the back to finish it off to
make it look really delicious you know
why not there's some make it rain and
parmesan on top and then we're gonna
make it rain parsley - yeah
this is pretty awesome guys mozzarella
sticks are finished they were plated
there we have it we have giant
mozzarella sticks shine on your rings
regular marinara sauce just a lot of it
I think Jake super hungry say no more
let's go eat hey Jake what's up dude are
you ready for your food yeah man let's
see it all right close your eyes though
all right I want to bring them in one by
one on the same a mouse is already
salivating a bit who is in front of you
okay hope you're hungry I think you
might be very happy with the results so
on the count of three I want you to open
your eyes all right all right one two
three your eyes dude oh my god that is a
huge yeah pretty good right just enough
for you to eat on long fingers each so
I'll crush at least a few of these I
hope so he's gonna be eating a lot dude
yes yeah we have some giant mozzarella
sticks got some giant onion rings and we
have some homemade marinara homemade oh
my oh you're going to the best part
about a mozzarella stick is you know
when you pull it you get that great
cheese Paul if you want one two three
give it a nice pull slow hot Sorella
this is someone I thought it keeps going
oh yes crazy oh here we go
alright well we got a dip first yep yeah
of course you can do i dip you dip we
all did I don't know what that song goes
but that's what it is
alright alright cheers dude man oh good
mmm Wow close it up dude this is unreal
this tastes so good it's good right it's
like a mantra stick sandwich this is
like the best thing ever
who's this like an innovative dish
Chumley's onion rings - oh whoa all
right yeah I'm just gonna do a dip mmm
well ha so have I just made it good yeah
yeah I'm good on you in there how do you
feel I feel good heaven God well I'm
happy I could make this for you I know
you guys might be playing some games
later you know if you want to bring this
to the guys a lot of food oh oh yeah
well I'll help you bring this over all
right all right soon in yeah yeah
spending tough day today you know we uh
cried a lot I sweated a lot but I would
say it's pretty successful Jake was
happy I was very impressed with just how
far the mozzarella pole got I think that
was probably one of my favorite China
food so far and you know this is the
second to last episode of this season of
making a big if you guys want to take a
guess at something cool that I have
prepared for you guys next week feel
free leave it in the comments send me a
message it's gonna be kind of crazy and
I think you'll know the person but I'm
making it for but until next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]